en apparence
vous êtes tous les cinq des voyous des
prédateurs
des sanctions pas de pitié je vous en
prie vous me faites rire
on est les bad guys
d'accord je t'en supplie soit subtil
je vais avoir en tête salez banda et
elle est si vous voulez éviter la prison
vous devez devenir gentil tu nous fais
quoi là nous allons faire semblant de
devenir gentil pour pouvoir rester
rentables
pouvez vous aider cette grand-mère
traverser la rue du croquet orient
on est plus que des méchants qui font
peur et nous m vous êtes ainsi gentil
petit car j'ai plus envie de quoi un bas
de gamme non nous serons toujours des
bagages je veux que vous partagiez le
nom loser ça valait le coup quand même
[Musique]